Bobby Wagner back here on the Rich Eisen
show how are you been Bobby I've been
good how about two now I'm hanging in
there I'm hanging in there what I'd love
to just start off right off the bat with
it
telling Seattle fans what to expect so
many guys that you've played with and
have been face front names that that
represent the type of style that Seattle
plays are no longer there including one
who's holding out what can you tell the
twelves about the upcoming season here
Bobby I feel like they have a lot to
look forward to their conversation I
feel like you know a lot of people are
riding this off but it's not a position
that we have been in we've been in this
position before I like moving when I
came in 2012-13 you know nobody had
expected to do anything or be good and
and we proved them wrong and it's a
similar feel to that you know you
understand that we you know we lost a
lot of people of familiar faces that
they you know grown used to but you know
it was only a matter of time you know
that happening you know I think we were
fortunate enough to all be together for
as long as work and you know I think
it's gonna be a great season looking
forward to it do you think you'll have
Earl Thomas playing behind you Bobby I'm
not sure I'm really not sure I don't
know I hope I hope he does but you know
the way the business is you know it's
not you know you can never retail it's
interesting to see the the star
defensive players out versus offensive
ones so you know that's that's another
story for itself let's dig into that
there what do you think defensive
players when they hold out don't get
theirs but offensive players who do do
I'm not saying I'm not saying that I
definitely say that you know this is the
authors of League so it's just
interesting to me that you have you know
great players like Leo Mac Eric Donald
you know yet to get paid you know given
what they've done in the lead you know
but you if they were quarterbacks I feel
like it would have been a little bit
different so it's just interesting
that since on phone you have guys that
have already got paid and you guys you
know haven't done as much as they've
done and Lee so it's just interesting to
me when it comes to that Bobby Wagner
here on the Rich Eisen show have you
spoken to Earl
lately I have not spoke to him at the
beginning of before we started up kind
of just you know reiterated my support
to him you know I understand the
business side of things or are hard but
you know I haven't really spoke to him
you know I think my folks he's been
getting ready everybody ready to play
this season you know we got a lot to get
done a lot to accomplish in you know we
have to focus on the people that's here
in this building right now and hoping
that you know at some point he's one of
them well obviously you know Michael
Bennett Averell I mean Richard Sherman
and with Earl holding out those are just
some names camp chancellor as well how
do you feel about your responsibility
and picking up the slack or being more
vocal than you normally would be Bobby
you know I feel like I'm excited for for
the challenge and I think you know I
think I see it from a different
perspective
I feel like personally the being vocal
and all that stuff that's kind of
already been been happening of our being
doing that but you know sort of not
really out there as far as media wise it
doesn't seem that way so it's not for me
it's not necessarily a big change you
know we lost a lot of guys that are very
vocal in the media so as far as that
that might be the the biggest change but
as far as in the locker room room feel I
you know I've always look at myself as
as the leader just because of you know
our Ken Norton jr. had you know he came
here to rundown about how to play the
middle linebacker position I think
that's a hard been trying to grow since
I came into the league so what did can
tell you about that that you put out
um that weird a quarterback for the
defense that we we run the show and that
we're in the middle of everything for a
reason and you know her our job is to go
satellites online make all the calls and
and you know make an effective game
that's what I try to do Bobby Wagner of
the Seattle Seahawks here on the Rich
Eisen show Bobby I have a list of NFL
quarterbacks here I'd like to run down
them one by one and tell me you tell me
if they suck or not okay Bobby we do
that somebody already did that really
because I thought you I think yeah okay
nice particularly let me again but the
entrance I guess or the requirement is
you may have to tell them everything you
think of the NFL quarterback position
and whether they sucker not Bobby I
think it's a little differently you
you're a cornerback so they gotta throw
against you all the time okay so running
backs and maybe maybe that man maybe I
have to talk about the running okay so
let's talk about Todd Gurley does he
suck Bobby
yeah I'm just kidding anyway what did
you think of it are you guys in your
locker room talking about what Jalen
Ramsey was was saying like that Bobby
honestly we I mean I read it I've seen
it it wasn't really like a big thing
because you know you kind of for me it's
like okay that's not nothing
new you know Richard you know it's been
in my locker room so you know yeah I've
seen the type of stuff Richard uh so you
know him doing that Ben didn't rub this
this locker room at all no yeah I know
but I'm just wondering you did take a
look at what he did think about Russell
Wilson though right Bobby you did look
for his oh no I didn't I didn't even see
I didn't see what he said about Russell
he said he's good
yeah good he gave him the Jacksonville
teal blue checkmark he gave him that
yeah it didn't seem he was given too
many people privacy he might have said
Tom Brady doesn't doesn't suck yeah I
guess so okay it did his purpose it was
supposed to do yeah Bobby Wagner CR at
Seattle Seahawks linebacker and should
be in gentlemen's quarterly right here
on the Rich Eisen show who's
in the football for you this year Bobby
can you give me an idea on that I don't
know I don't know yeah you know I think
definitely Chris Carson is been very
very impressive you know Rashad is going
to be out with the injury for a while
but you know in Chris Carson has
impressed me
you know since since he's got back from
his injury so that's what I would assume
but it's kind of not you know I'm I
started applause I let them matter
they're know I know I'm just want I'm
you you you don't ever peek over there
to see what's going on to see how things
are progressing on that sideline
protection wise certainly for Russell
Wilson etc definitely because we you
know we gonna get some you know every
single day so you definitely see the
improvements in the old line you know
like I said you know what you see you
know it's a different from you know
Chris Carson runs the ball he's just you
know he stands out to me you know every
time you watch him you know whether it's
him out of the backfield or in the blog
he stands out so you know I felt like we
kind of got a glimpse of that last year
for me he got hurt so I'm excited to see
how that looks 16 games but I mean he
looks really really strong and he looks
like he's on a mission a few more
minutes left here with the man who's
made the last four Pro Bowlers four Pro
Bowls entering his seventh season in the
NFL Bobby Wagner so sure Marco Thomas is
the first player in the National
Football League to get ejected under the
new helmet rule he went ahead and he
crushed DJ more on your team and that
looked like exactly the type of play
that the NFL is trying to get out of the
game what is your thought on this new
rule how it's being applied how it's
been explained to you so far Bobby I
kind of feel like it's gonna be
interested to you know I feel like right
now it's kind of easy to kind of go
along with it because it's a preseason
and you know trying to work the kinks
out of everything and trying to figure
out how they're gonna call it but um you
know I think it's gonna be interesting
interesting when it games too
two real games especially when it comes
to the quarterback or the running back
or the ball carrier period you know if
you got a guy going for the first down
marker and he leads with his head I'm
not sure we have an answer on what a
defensive player is supposed to do same
thing if he's reaching for the goal line
you know if a guy is you know going for
the goal line and trying to score a
touchdown and it's that split second and
you you know all you have is the you
know the runner or the quarterback or
the receiver you know they leave with
their head to try to get into the end
zone you know I'm not sure you know what
we do but as far as like you know trying
to take the Hat again you know like a
hit like that you not understand
you know you don't want nobody to lead
with their head and hit somebody with
the crown of the head on on that I get
that but there there's still a lot of
hits that we need some clarity - of
course they're going to protect the
quarterbacks of course you're gonna look
out for the quarterbacks that's that's a
given but you know I think every year
they try to find a way to make the game
harder for its players but you know we
adapt and we adjust and we figure it out
you know it's always every every
offseason it's always no defensive rule
is rarely you know offensive rules so I
think it's gonna be interesting to see
how they enforce it during the season I
hope that it's not a bunch of rejections
during the year because this is how
people provide for their family I
understand the safety of the game and
how they're trying to do that so I'm
just intrigued to see you know how they
forced a new rule but I mean we're fine
I'll never use my head to tackle so yeah
to worry about it because the yeah I
guess just to wrap this up the
conversation that I hear you know we've
had Troy Vincent on we've had you know
we've had to the head of NFL rough Sal
River on on and I've you know talking to
folks in the league the what I hear is
like this is preseason you know it's
preseason for the officials to but they
want to throw more flags now to let
everybody know that this is in the
rulebook and that when and that players
will adjust that's what I keep hearing
those words players will adjust our are
you sensing that folks in your
locker room or your colleagues around
the league are adjusting ready to adjust
defensive players will adjust but yeah I
think they kind of told us that before
they they told us they were going to be
a little more aggressive in a true
season with some of these callers just
to kind of show us an idea of what could
potentially be something worth flagging
what can particularly something worth
ejections and things that are nature I'm
not they've definitely done a great job
of trying to you know communicate you
know what they're going to do I just
feel like it's it's a lot different when
it comes to regular season and playoff
games and when you know these games
matter and and and stuff is on the line
and you know you got guys selling out to
you know get a first down or a touchdown
or whatever the case may be and try to
figure out well you know what we're
going to do or you know what's the
judgment you know a lot of it is you
know the difference plays have a chance
to think about the hit you know it's
kind of hard you're not really in that
person's shoes you don't know what he's
thinking in the moment or you know the
game happens a lot faster than a they
think and so it's going to be
interesting to see how they call it in
you know during the season but from as
far as the games that I've watched and
the things that I've seen you know the
stuff that they've called penalties you
know looked pretty legit and stuff that
you know there's there's been a lot of
things that we were concerned that they
were going to call it they haven't so
you know I don't think it's going to
affect the game as much as people think
okay last one for a Jimmy Garoppolo does
he suck Bobby does Issa we don't know
yet we don't know yet it's only five
games we got it we got to figure this is
gonna be the test now did the whole
season okay see all right you can go
we'll be all good when we get when we
get like game 14 I'll get back on the
phone and and I and I ask that question
for tastic I look forward to that Bobby
always love our chats thanks for calling
in right back at you appreciate you too
Bobby Wagner adbe wags with a Z on
Twitter right here in the Rich Eisen
show the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience